can be balanced with an individual's
right to privacy
[Music]
this week on q a
author and former new york times
correspondent stephen kinser discusses
his new book titled the brothers john
foster dulles allen dulles and their
secret world war
[Music]
stephen kenzer in your book the brothers
john foster dulles and alan dulles you
tell a story up front about dulles
airport in washington and the statue
and the naming what what is that
john foster dulles had recently died
when that super airport out in chantilly
virginia was being built
and president eisenhower immediately
announced that the airport would be
named dulles airport
for a while when kennedy took over he
didn't want to name it after a crusty
old cold warrior but there was pushback
from others and finally the decision was
made to name it after dulles
you can still see the film clip of
kennedy opening uh the airport with
eisenhower there and alan dulles there
and he pulls back a curtain
and behind the curtain is this giant
bust of john foster dulles and that bus
stands in the middle of this big airport
so i went to see it while i was writing
this book and i couldn't find it i
started asking the security guards
where's the big bust of dulles nobody
had ever even heard of it it was a long
process and finally thanks to the
washington airports authority i was able
to discover that the bust had been taken
away from its place in the middle of the
airport and it's now in a closed
conference room opposite baggage claim
number three and i find this a wonderful
metaphor for how the dulles brothers who
at one time exercised earth-shattering
power and were able to make and break
governments
have now been effectively forgotten and
airbrushed out of our entire history who
were or who was alan dulles and who was
john foster doss
these two brothers were about the most
extraordinary pair of siblings to emerge
in american history at least up to that
point
they grew up in an atmosphere of a
religious piety they grew up in a
parsonage
and were deeply influenced by the ideals
of missionary calvinism the idea that
the world's divided between good and
evil and that christians have to go out
into the world and transform the evil
into good
it's a very short step from that
religious view to take it into politics
and believe that politically the world
is divided between good regimes and evil
regimes and that it's the duty of the
good regimes that's us to go out in the
world and destroy the evil ones so
that's an important part of the dulles
brothers formation and the other big
influence on them i think was the
decades that they spent
as corporate lawyers working for this
very important law firm sullivan and
cromwell in new york
that was not a law firm that you went to
if you needed a contract drawn up or if
you needed to be represented in a
courtroom sullivan and cromwell had a
specialty and that was pressuring
small and weak countries to accept the
demands of big american corporations and
that was what alan dulles and foster
dulles devoted their lives to doing so
in their own minds the interests of the
united states
in the interests of big american
multinational corporations became the
same thing so they came into office one
as secretary of state and the younger
brother as director of the cia with
these two influences this uh religious
view of the world being divided between
good and evil and many years of working
for corporations that shape their view
of how american foreign policy should
work
when was john foster dulles secretary of
state
both of them came to power at the same
time they were sworn in immediately
after president eisenhower took office
in 1953. it was the only time in
american history
that siblings have controlled the overt
and the covert sides of foreign policy
you have a second part of your book
about six monsters and i've got the
pictures here and i'm going to point out
the first one is mozadek if i could get
a brief synopsis from you about who they
are we can get into the substance of
this
in 1821 john quincy adams made a famous
speech on the fourth of july and he said
america does not go abroad in search of
monsters to destroy
but the dulles brothers did
they were carrying out a secret world
war even at a time in the 1950s when we
thought we were at peace and they went
after six monsters six figures that they
found evil in the world one right after
the other the first in 1953 was prime
minister masadek of iran who they
overthrew in august of that year the
next year 1954 they overthrew president
arbenz in guatemala
the next year they launched an operation
against ho chi minh that failed
miserably and actually was the operation
that dragged the united states into the
vietnam war
then they went after sucarno the
president of indonesia and fomented a
civil war there they went after patrice
lumumba the elected prime minister of
the congo right after independence in
1960 and their last monster was fidel
castro who also
survived their attempts to depose him
where were they born
the dulles brothers were born and grew
up in
watertown new york uh actually foster
dulles was born in washington briefly
because the mother came here to live
with her father for a few months her
father had been secretary of state owned
a big house near uh dupont circle but
watertown new york on the shores of lake
ontario was kind of a playground for the
new york rich the father was actually
not a plutocrat he was a clergyman but
the family was extraordinary so these
two brothers as young kids
grew up in a religious environment they
said their prayers every day in the
morning they would take a cold shower
only kind their father would allow uh
say their prayers sing a few hymns and
then they were free to run down to the
shores of lake ontario
where their two distinguished and doting
relatives were waiting to take them out
fishing and those two relatives
were both secretaries of state
their grandfather john watson foster had
been secretary of state in the 1890s and
he was actually the first secretary of
state to preside over the overthrow of a
foreign government that was the
government of hawaii so actually the
dulles family got into the regime change
business even before the dulles brothers
were born
and their uncle robert lansing was
secretary of state during world war one
so they grew up in this very elite
environment as young boys they were
brought to washington to stay at
grandfather foster's mansion and they
were having dinner with grover cleveland
and woodrow wilson and andrew carnegie
and bernard baruch and william howard
taft
as children they were able to absorb not
just the ideas of the american elite but
their their style the perception the way
this elite looked at the world this is
why i see them as kind of
vessels of american history imagine
their grandfather john watson foster
campaigned for abraham lincoln
and they in office
projected american power all over the
world during the nuclear age why did you
get interested in them and when
i wrote a book years ago called bitter
fruit about how the united states
overthrew the arbenz government in
guatemala the dulles brothers played key
roles in that overthrow years later i
wrote another book called all the shah's
men about how the united states
overthrew the government of iran the
dulles brothers were also players in a
very important way in that operation
i became more and more interested as i
began to realize how central the dulles
brothers are not were
in the 1950s
probably every literate human being in
the world knew the name dulles
but now when we look around the world we
really are still seeing the results of
the dulles brothers policies look at the
tragedy that unfolded in guatemala with
200 000 dead in a civil war and
guatemala sliding toward failed narco
state status look at what we've seen in
iran
50 60 years of tyranny first under arsha
then under religious fundamentalists all
of that started with the dulles brothers
look what's happened in the congo you
have had literally millions killed there
in the last decade or two it was the
dulles brothers who first intervened to
promote the overthrow and execution of
the first elected leader of the congo
the vietnam war was principally the
product of john foster dulles's
determination
not to go along with the french and
british and say well ho chi minh won the
war there's nothing we can do but he
decided to go and fight so when you look
around the world
you see today the results of the dulles
brothers interventions we've now
forgotten them and
i'm trying to bring them back to life
and show how not only they were central
to shaping the world we now know but how
they reflect many deep impulses in the
american psyche and the american body
politic we have some video from 1952
to be able to see what john foster
dulles looked and sounded like
are we stronger this year as against
russia than we were last year
i think probably not it's pretty hard to
judge those things but
my estimate would be that the
tide is still running against us
everywhere i look around the world the
question is
what maybe we're gonna lose next you
know and uh we seem to be on the
defensive and that they're on the
offensive the question is uh what are we
going to lose each year more than what
are we going to gain you can look around
the whole circle of the world
and you find one spot after another
after another after another where the
question is are we going to lose this
bit of the free world is it going to be
iran or is it going to be egypt or is it
going to be indoor china or is it going
to be korea or what's it going to be
you go back to his beginning and you
talked about elite schools and all that
where did he go early in his life to
school
his mother didn't think public schools
were good enough for him so they engaged
a number of private tutors and then he
went on to princeton
and was quite an outstanding student
there his brother also went to princeton
but they although developed a
totally
united view of the world they always saw
the world in the exact same way
politically and ideologically they were
perfect twins
but in their personalities they were
totally different foster dulles as you
can see for that from that clip was very
dour
very unfriendly very uh
off-putting i read in one book even his
friends didn't like him
alan dulles was exactly the opposite he
was a sparkling conversationalist let me
interrupt just to show you some video of
alan dulles so people and by the way
they're not twins what was the
difference in their ages exactly they
were five years apart they were twins
politically and ideologically but not g
not uh biological who was older foster
dulles was the older
let's look at alan dulles for a moment
so we can continue
there are times
when the united states government feels
that the developments in another
government
such as in the vietnam situation
is of a nature
uh to imperil these
the safety and the security and the
peace of the world
and ask the central intelligence agency
to be its agent in that particular
situation
at no time has the cia engaged in any
political activity or any intelligence
activity
it was not approved
at the highest level
he was interviewed by john chancellor of
nbc and from a program called the
science of spying a documentary
what was alan dulles like compared to
his brother
he was a sparkling conversationist had
endless
stock of stories loved great wine he was
a
inveterate adulterer he probably had a
hundred affairs from claire booth loose
to the queen of greece
and he was very seductive also for
americans i think
in washington he seemed like such a nice
guy
that uh
you've got the feeling that maybe he
couldn't be doing anything so bad he was
not only the head of the invisible
government he was the ambassador of the
invisible government to the visible
government now he was absolutely correct
when he said that cia operations were
all approved at the highest levels
meaning by president eisenhower but
there's another piece of this when you
saw john foster dulles in that clip
lamenting about the world being slipping
away from the united states and falling
away from freedom the fact is right
while he was making that clip in 1953
stalin had just died and the new leader
leaders in the kremlin wanted to have a
summit of their new leaders with the
western allies and winston churchill
thought this was a great idea the prime
minister of france wanted to do it try
to negotiate with the soviets and see if
we could manage our competition foster
dulles was absolutely opposed he was
against all contact with any government
that we didn't like
so when he describes the world as being
in complete confrontation he omits the
fact that he was one of the principal
figures who intensified and maintained
that confrontation the women in their
lives
you do cite when they met their
the women that they married and how
quick i mean they made decisions rather
quickly explain for both of them
actually uh their wives reflected the
differences between them
the woman that john foster dulles
married had dated alan dulles a couple
of times but alan dulles found her very
stayed and boring so he quickly moved on
but stayed and boring was just what
foster dulles liked so uh
she janet avery the woman that uh john
foster dulles married uh was with him
his whole life i'm sure both of them
were completely faithful and janet was
really his only friend he would spend
his evenings at home and they would play
bridge or he would read a detective
novel while she knitted that was the
extent of
their wildness but
alan dulles married a very interesting
woman
she
had a lot of emotional and psychological
problems some of them no doubt the
result of
a very unfeeling and unpleasant husband
since the husband made no secret of his
adulteries but she became very
interested in causes like prison reform
and i think she began feeling
uncomfortable in the relationship they
never actually divorced although they
talked about it a number of times but by
the time alan dulles was head of the cia
they were effectively living separate
lives why would alan dulles write his
wife
and tell her about his affairs
i sometimes wonder about that was it
just that he was unfeeling and didn't
realize how hurtful that would be
or was he actually trying to insult and
humiliate her it's remarkable when you
see what a wonderfully outgoing
person he was and how everybody loved
him and then compare this with how
harshly and unfeelingly he treated his
wife maybe it reflects something that's
true in many of us uh we're all for
loving people in general but it's a
little more difficult when we have to
love individuals what where did you find
the a lot of the the
affairs that you write about where was
the information this information is
scattered in a lot of places and one of
the things that drove me in writing this
book is that nobody has in this century
ever focused on the dulles brothers i
immersed myself in particular in the uh
princeton university archives where both
dulles brothers have deposited their
papers there's a lot of rich stuff in
there including oral histories that
refer to many of these
affairs and also other
curious aspects that have never been
published before about the dulles
brothers so i've tried to present a
picture of them not just as political
leaders but as people who were they i'm
a great believer in telling stories and
i want people to finish a chapter and
want to turn the page to find out what
happens next this is not like an
academic study and there have been good
academic studies of the dulles brothers
in office but that's not what this is
there is a person that a lot of
americans might know now
who was named after janet avery
he turned out to be a cardinal in the
catholic church
i want to show some video of him and
then explain the relationship between
john foster dulles a strict presbyterian
calvinist
and
a cardinal
who is his own son
that the government has an interest in
seeing that the
moral tone of society is kept in order
just to for the sake of the observance
of law and the making of law it's very
important that people have the right
moral and religious values and so i hope
that many will feel that is an important
thing even though they can't directly
legislate morality or law or morality or
religion they nevertheless can
can
support it in various ways
by their own example and the
tone of their lives
what was cardinal dulles relationship
with his father
actually i found out something about
that that i don't think has ever been
published buried in an oral history that
had been embargoed for some years in the
uh princeton dulles archive
in that oral history uh it's an
interview with one of the law partners
at sullivan and cromwell one of foster
dulles's partners and he says one day
foster dulles called me frantically and
said this is the worst day of my life
you've got to come in right now into my
office so i went to his office and he i
saw him very upset and he handed me a
letter and he asked me to read it and
the letter was to his son avery who had
just decided to become a catholic now
for someone like john foster dallas
it would have been better if his son had
become a hindu a catholic was just
absolutely intolerable and in this
letter
foster dulles writes to his son never
speak to me again never call me again
you are not my son you are not alive to
me anymore i have nothing to do with you
and this partner recalls that he said i
spent four hours with dulles that
afternoon and finally persuaded him not
to send the letter nonetheless
their relationship was quite strained
until late in life and i don't think
that foster dulles could ever come to
grips with the fact that he had a
catholic in his family my memory is that
avery dallas died at in the 90s yes he
lived to quite an advanced age uh
how did he become a cardinal
he was a very conservative theologian
and his conservatism and his
conservative writings uh attracted the
attention of pope john paul ii
and uh without going through the normal
uh rise in the hierarchy that cardinals
normally go through
uh avery dulles was named by pope john
paul ii uh directly as a card what did
it mean to be a presbyterian in the
dallas's early days
i think what it meant was to see the
world
as made up of good and evil
in other cultures and other traditions
we sometimes think that all people and
all governments are made up of good and
evil impulses and these impulses come
out in different proportions depending
on circumstances
but
calvinism doesn't teach you that and
foster dulles not only grew up in a
religious environment but missionaries
who were coming back from syria from
china and other parts of the uh
undeveloped world were regular guests in
their homes so he grew up hearing these
stories about the need to go out and
convert the heathens and the savages and
the unbelievers
and i think he took that christian ethos
and applied it to politics
by the way there's never any uh mention
that i can remember in here of him being
anti-anything else uh
where did he get his why was he
anti-catholic
i think it's a part of uh
traditional conservative uh calvinism
that
the catholic church went off in a
terrible direction became evil
and that
protestantism uh or calvinism was the
true church therefore
catholics were seen as agents of the
devil it's hard to imagine but there was
intense anti-catholic feeling in this
country for many years and foster dallas
was certainly an exemplar of that john
foster dulles died when and of what and
the same thing for alan dulles and how
long was alan dulles the head of the
c.i.a
foster dulles died in office or actually
he had resigned just a couple of weeks
before as he was quite ill he died in
1959
and
americans mourned his passing
they had always thought of him as the
tough guy who snarled at them and he was
never popular or beloved but when he
died there was an outpouring of grief
the funeral was carried live on
nationwide television
he faded from national memory but at
least he died before his reputation
began to decline the same did not happen
to alan dulles allen was still alive
when john f kennedy was elected
president one of kennedy's very first uh
announcements after the election just
two days after he was elected was that
he was going to keep alan dulles on
as head of the cia
and the first operation that alan dulles
directed for president kennedy was the
bay of pigs invasion of cuba
that was such a disaster that president
kennedy asked his aides in fury how
could i have been so stupid
shortly thereafter he fired alan dulles
so alan dulles did live to see his
reputation decline and died later in the
1960s well go back to the original story
about naming
the airport which is 26 miles outside of
washington dulles international versus
chantilly international which the
kennedys supposedly wanted to name it
when did
jack kennedy president kennedy change
his mind about that name and how did
they get it back on track then
you're absolutely right it was
eisenhower's idea that the airport
should be named after dulles but dulles
was a crusty old cold warrior and
kennedy represented a new era so when he
came in he didn't like the idea of
naming the airport after dulles they
were going to name it chantilly there
was even some talk of naming it after
george marshall
but alan dulles and others around him
launched a pressure campaign against
president kennedy and against the head
of the federal aviation administration
uh najib halaby and kennedy finally gave
in and decided he didn't need to pick a
fight on this one i think even
eisenhower was indirectly pushing
kennedy to name it after dulles so uh
we got this airport and you know i used
to think it was an awful thing looking
back and considering the legacy of the
dulles brothers that this airport
carries that name but now i feel
differently because
if that airport didn't have that name
nobody would even know who the dulles
brothers were and i can tell you that
while i was writing this book
sometimes people would ask me what's
your new book about and i'd say i'm
writing a book about dulles and they
said the airport
how long did you write for the new york
times
i was 23 years with the new york times
and that's an indirect uh
reason why i got interested in these
operations when i was working for the
new york times covering big events in
the middle east and in europe and in
latin america
i was always frustrated uh at writing
only about what happened today
what i was really interested in is
what happened yesterday how did we get
here why is this happening
when i get to countries like guatemala
iran i always ask myself
why is this country like this why is a
country poor and miserable why is the
country rich and powerful
over and over i was able to trace the
answers in countries that have fallen
into chaos like the congo and iran and
guatemala
back to the dulles brothers so i'm
following history back and trying to
find out why the world today is the way
it is and a lot of the answers to that
question have to do with the dulles
brothers when you were at the new york
times how many different places did you
live
i had three foreign assignments my first
one was in central america i covered all
the wars of el salvador and guatemala
and the contra war in nicaragua that was
where i lived after nicaragua
i was sent off to berlin right at the
time the wall was falling
european unification was starting and
the wars in yugoslavia also became a big
part of my job
and then i became the first new york
times bureau chief in istanbul which was
a great assignment partly because it
allowed me to start getting into iran
and beginning to understand a country
that
we have a lot of difficulty
understanding because our emotions are
so intense when i got to iran i remember
asking people
why is a country with this history and
this culture
so unhappy and miserable and isolated
and poor and people told me
actually we had a democracy here once
but the dulles brothers came over here
and destroyed it i didn't know anything
about that i don't think most americans
did or do
and so this book is trying you know
among other things to explain to
americans
not only why some countries in the world
have fallen into this chaos after
american intervention
but who organized that intervention and
what were the forces that propelled
those interventions i want to come back
to around just a second but you left the
new york times what year and what are
you doing now besides writing books i
left the new york times in 2006
after 23 years
and i'm now visiting fellow at the
watson institute for international
studies at brown university which i'm
much enjoying and what other
institutions where have you taught this
is my third university when i was living
in chicago i taught at northwestern and
then i went on to boston university my
alma mater and i'm now thrilled being at
brown
here's alan dulles talking about mosadek
and we'll ask you more about that after
we watch a little with us
the government of mosaddegh if you
recall history was overthrown by the
action of the shah
now that we encourage the shah to take
that action i will not deny
[Applause]
actually the shah had tried to fire
premier mohamed mossadeg and had failed
with the help of cia and british
operatives though he was finally ousted
mossadegg's crimes had been his
nationalization of the great pool of
persian oil and his flirtation with the
russians when it was all over the west
had held onto the oil and mossadegg had
only his famous tears
what's the back story on this
the back story is really fascinating and
it's one of the stories i tell in the
book
as private lawyers john foster dulles
and alan dulles represented many of
america's biggest corporations
what they promised those clients is we
will protect you nothing will ever
happen to your foreign operations as
long as you have us as your lawyers but
two things happen in 1951
that uh
showed they couldn't keep their promise
number one muhammad mossad nationalized
the iranian oil industry and that had
formally belonged to a company called
the anglo-iranian oil company and the
financial agent for that oil company was
something called the schroeder bank
which was represented by sullivan and
cromwell and in fact alan dulles was on
the board of directors of the schroeder
bank so he had to go to the schroeder
bank people and say i failed you hired
me to protect your interest in iran and
i couldn't do it because of mussodek
almost immediately thereafter in
guatemala
the congress passed a land reform act
that required united fruit company to
sell its unused land to the government
so it could be parceled out and given to
peasants so the dulles brothers had to
go to united fruit company and say we
failed we couldn't protect you and they
didn't like to fail so they developed a
deep grudge against muslim iran and
arbenz in guatemala they couldn't do
anything about it because they were only
private lawyers but they carried that
grudge with them into office and their
very first project
as soon as they took office in 1953 was
to plot against mussodek and the moment
they had overthrown him they turned and
overthrew our bends so they carried this
grudge
and it was a grudge based essentially
on the fact that these two leaders most
deck and iran and arbenz in guatemala
had
deeply wounded companies that the dulles
brothers had promised to protect that
was a crime that they never forgave
then beyond that there were four other
monsters that you talk about uh and how
did they get involved in that and what
drove them to the ho chi minh and fidel
castro and
lumumba and all and they were in office
when they did this and what was their
motive
you're quite right they carried these
two grudges with them into office
masadek and arbenz but the others were
grudges or enmities that they developed
while in office the vietnam story is
fascinating and really tragic john
foster dulles was the american delegate
to a big conference in geneva in 1954 to
discuss the future of vietnam that was
right at the time when the french
had suffered their big defeat at diane
van fu and had very reluctantly
concluded we lost the war
we can't defeat ho chi minh
and it's breaking our heart but we have
to throw in the towel and winston
churchill agreed with them he had a
great line to foster dulles he said the
loss of the fortress must be faced
in other words
we don't like it but ho chi minh is very
popular and nobody can defeat him
but foster dulles refused to believe
that he said well of course you all
europeans don't know how to defeat
someone like ho chi minh but we can do
it if he had made a different decision
on his way home from the geneva
conference that one person on that one
day
the united states would never have
become involved in the vietnam war that
is really one of the great legacies of
foster dulles personally
having failed to topple uh ho chi minh
they then went on to another leader in
the neighborhood that was tsukarno in
indonesia his great crime was to embrace
an ideology that the dallas brothers
detested almost as much as they tested
bolshevism and that was neutralism they
were trying to undermine the entire
foundation of the cold war by saying
countries don't have to choose between
moscow and washington we're not involved
in this conflict that drove foster
dulles and allen dulles crazy their idea
was as foster dulles like to put it our
policy is global and he called
neutralism immoral
so he insisted that people like sucarno
show that they were pro-american
otherwise he would assume they were
anti-american and the dulles brothers
fomented a major civil war in indonesia
in the mid-1950s it failed however
it created tensions that exploded during
the 1960s and led to a horrific massacre
in which about a million indonesians
were killed
another neutralist who emerged in the
world during this period was patrice
lumumba in the congo this was a brand
new country just given independence by
belgium they elected this very
interesting but also quite a militantly
neutralist figure patrice lumumba and a
very young man exactly it was a very
undeveloped political culture this was a
time when there were there were no
congolese lawyers no congolese doctors
no congolese who had any experience in
government so you have to understand
that how underdeveloped belgium had left
the congo but the belgians and the
americans were terrified of lumumba
because he was so popular not just in
the congo but throughout the third world
and they organized a plot in which
lumumba was overthrown and assassinated
even before he had completed six months
in office
um
and their final target was fidel castro
alan dulles
organized the bay of pigs invasion
and in my chapter about this i take that
from a somewhat different perspective i
noticed as i was reading through a lot
of these private documents
something that i don't think has come
out in other histories of the bay of
pigs and it's this
allen dulles never attended any of the
meetings that planned the bay of pigs
invasion he didn't know what was
happening he left it to subordinates and
he wasn't even in washington on the day
of the invasion
i believe he was already suffering from
the beginnings of dementia a few years
later he was found wandering around in
georgetown not knowing how to find his
way home and i think the bay of pigs uh
disaster is in part the result of alan
dulles's complete disconnection and his
the beginning of his fade why did
president eisenhower go to these two men
in the first place what would what have
they done that was attractive to him
foster dulles had been the chief foreign
policy advisor to eisenhower during the
presidential campaign so it was the
logical
choice
alan dulles was a little different he
was renowned as a terrible administrator
and there was some fear not enough
unfortunately of having two brothers in
those important positions
after his inauguration and after looking
at various other candidates eisenhower
finally did uh appoint alan dulles now
in the years that have followed
eisenhower's leaving office there's been
a lot of debate about the role of the
dulles brothers compared to eisenhower
so did the dulles brothers manipulate
eisenhower did they feed him false
information
did they act behind his back or did he
approve everything they did
we now know that that latter one was
true eisenhower knew everything they
were doing and he approved everything
including the assassination of two
foreign leaders he personally approved
the assassination of lumumba and
attempts to assassinate fidel castro how
do you know we find this in the
documents
he doesn't actually use the word murder
and assassinate but if you go through
the book i have quoted the actual
meetings minutes of which have much
later been declassified and
recollections of people who are in those
meetings and you'll see the
circumlocutious but very clear orders
from eisenhower now some people have
raised this question
why would eisenhower have been so much
in favor of covert operations
we don't know for sure because he never
spoke about it that was an age when you
believed secrets should be taken to the
grave
but i think there were two reasons why
eisenhower so strongly supported these
covert regime change operations
one is that although nobody knew it at
the time
covert operations were very important in
winning world war ii we broke the german
codes we had all kinds of fake army
units with tanks that were actually
blown up balloons to deceive the germans
so eisenhower of course as commander of
the allied forces would have known about
all these operations and i'm sure that
he came away from the world war ii
experience with a deep appreciation for
what covert operations could do and the
other reason is that i think he would
have seen covert operations as a peace
project you don't have to wage war and
kill tens of thousands you can do this
covertly with only the death of dozens
or hundreds you mentioned that alan
dallas had an affair with claire booth
loose yes she did yes they did
how do you know that
um we know it from a series of sources
including alan's mistress and as a
matter of fact alan's mistress was at
that time having an affair with henry
loos
so it was kind of a very closed small
circle and i think this was pretty
clearly understood and i'll tell you a
funny thing that i found in my research
and this is just a speculation on my
part of course henry luce and alan
dulles were quite friendly not only were
they sleeping with each other's partners
but they knew each other socially and
were politically very much in line
one of uh alan dulles's paramours was
the queen of greece one day henry luce
who was the publisher of time magazine
put the queen of greece on the cover of
time magazine and there's a little quote
at the bottom and it says
my strength is the love of the people i
wonder was he sending a kind of a quiet
little jokey message to alan bellas well
you mentioned more than once henry lewis
and time magazine and the covers and
with the allen dulles and the john
foster dulles covers and also some of
these folks
that you write about as the monsters
explain the role of time magazine played
it's hard to believe now that one person
or one empire could have such reach
because our media landscape is so
fractured but between time magazine and
life magazine and march of time
newsreels and radio broadcasts
uh henry lewis probably reached half or
more of the literate population of the
united states and henry luce was very
much like
the dulles brothers so he also was a
strict presbyterian
he had been born in china son of
missionaries he came from a missionary
line just like the dulles brothers did
so they work very closely together one
supporting the other
and for example one great story has to
do with uh the time that patrice lumumba
was supposed to be on the cover of time
magazine and they actually made the
portrait but at the very last moment uh
the american government under
particularly the cia became terrified
they didn't want more publicity they
didn't want this handsome figure on the
cover of time magazine
so they managed to call henry lewis at
the very last moment as the
magazine was actually going to press and
finally loose agreed to take lumumba off
but they didn't have time to make a new
portrait so they took an old picture of
doug hummershall the u.n secretary
general and they pasted it against the
background of tropical trees and african
landscape that had been intended for
lumumba so you can now buy the portrait
of lumumba on the cover of time that
never got to the cover of time but can
you also see the dog hammer shoulder
cover and see the the background yes
absolutely and it's quite incongruous
because dog hummersheld should have been
portrayed against a very different
background so you've got the
background of lumumba but the picture of
this
scandinavian diplomat you point out in
your book that ho chi minh was in new
york and worked in new york as a pastry
chef for a while here's some video of
him
and then i want you to put him in
context
ho chi minh
is of the blood sweat and tears school
you don't fight the revolution for 30
years getting clobbered at every turn
until finally you come out on top
without being off the blood sweat into
your school it's dangerous to second
thing or the second guess a man like ho
chi minh they're much more complicated
than that
but i'm very much afraid that if ho chi
minh were to make up his mind that this
is the war to see through
that he might just be the man to see you
through too
the aged president is still a ferocious
nationalist and a shrewd communist
revolutionary
this month the united states made
abundantly clear its willingness to
negotiate for peace
it's now up to the old man in hanoi
[Music]
the first voice you heard by the way was
bernard fall famous uh historian and
author and the second was walter
cronkite ho chi minh
what impact did the dulles brothers have
on the vietnam war and how did it work
well you're right that ho chi minh did
turn up as a pastry chef actually at the
parker house hotel in boston and he
traveled a lot in the world
so during world war ii
ho chi minh was leading a resistance
force against the japanese invaders and
we supported him the united states
dropped weapons to him and even dropped
cigarette cases to him which is what he
asked for and we sent an oss mission to
help him and train him and work with his
men
when the war ended
the head of this mission had a private
dinner with ho chi minh as he was
leaving
and he said to ho chi minh i have to ask
you one question
are you a communist
and ho chi minh replied
yes
but i hope that doesn't mean we can't
still be friends
to the dulles brothers it did mean that
the fact is ho chi minh was a
nationalist and a communist
but the dulles brothers only saw the
communist part
not only did they feel impelled
to wage war against him but they really
thought they could win
they had this uh exaggerated view of
american power that whenever we start
something we can win
and it was that arrogance that brought
the united states into the war in
vietnam what was the source of their
anti-communism
i think it came from their
long formation as
members of the american elite and then
of course decades working to support the
power of american corporations in the
world
communist ideology was always aimed at
restricting the ability of international
corporations to work freely in many
other countries
but
there's something beyond just ideology
that i think must have driven them it's
this idea that there's always a horrible
force out there and that's why i start
my book with a quote from captain ahab
and moby dick
he says
that inscrutable thing
is chiefly what i hate and be the white
whale agent or be the white whale
principal i will wreak my hate upon him
you also write in your book about diego
rivera's
famous painting glorious victory in
which
you can see
john foster dallas
his brother right behind him with a
satchel full of money
and uh
general eisenhower down here in a bomb
why did you pick this uh and write about
it i consider this to be one of the most
brilliant works of political art of the
20th century and while i was writing
this book since the dulles brothers are
right in the middle of the picture i
decided i got to go see that picture
i've studied it of course in
reproductions over many years but i had
to go see it but i couldn't find it it
should have been in mexico we checked
with every diego rivera group finally i
tracked it down
it's in a museum in moscow
i was willing to go to moscow and i
wrote to the museum director and i got
back a note saying i'm sorry to tell you
that this picture is not on display it's
too big it's 16 feet long it's on a roll
in the basement if you come to moscow i
will take you to the basement and show
you the roll but i can't open it because
we don't have any space so this led me
to the following conclusion
that picture is not serving any purpose
in the basement of a museum in moscow
nor is the
nor are the russians the real audience
for it i have a suggestion for what we
should do with that picture let us see
if we can't take it or borrow it from
the russians and we should put that up
as the centerpiece of dulles airport and
find the old bust of dulles and put it
in front of that and that painting would
i think then stimulate not just memories
above dulles but questions about who he
was
what he did and who we are that allowed
him to do these things
you wrote
at the end in a chapter called the face
of god
foster and alan were chief promoters of
that fear they did as much as anyone to
shape america's confrontation with the
soviet union their actions helped set
off some of the world's most profound
long-term crisis
uh
why did they
why did why were they such heroes back
then and then why have they faded them
because the long-term effects of their
operations were not clear then it seemed
like everything they had done succeeded
they got rid of most of dick and iran
they got rid of
our benz in guatemala we never knew that
iran was going to spin down into this
horrible crisis or what was going to
happen in the congo after they
assassinated lumumba so at the time
they seemed very successful and very
heroic but in history from a historical
perspective i think you can see they
made a couple of huge
misjudgments number one
after stalin died
they completely refused to respond to
peace feelers from the kremlin they
never tried to see if the new leadership
would like to develop a new relationship
with the americans number two they
completely misunderstood
third world nationalism which emerged
after world war ii they saw it as just a
kremlin organized plot that's not what
it was and their final huge misjudgment
was that they had no idea of what we
today call blowback they never thought
that their operations would have
horrible effects decades and generations
later you say they're talking about
foster dulles he conveyed a harsh
snarling image that alienated millions
and contributed to generations of
anti-americanism why didn't why didn't
general eisenhower have that same impact
eisenhower smiled a lot uh john foster
dulles never smiled
one example is that
in many of these developing countries
like say
indonesia afghanistan the leaders
invited both
soviet officials and american officials
to visit they wanted eisenhower to come
but eisenhower wouldn't go because
foster dulles told him
countries that are not a hundred percent
on our side don't deserve a presidential
visit so you'd have these smiling
figures from the kremlin
showing up in these countries and
promoting a positive image
of soviet communism and meanwhile
there was no counterbalance except for
this snarling anger that came from
washington and i think that did
undermine the ability of the united
states to project our positive values
where did you find this little tidbit
foster spoke regularly to the american
people often from a collapsible podium
he carried on his plane so he could make
quote departure statements unquote and
arrival statements and he periodically
appealed to europeans but his
communications efforts stopped there
actually that also comes from a
previously embargoed oral history that's
at the princeton dulles archive one of
the aides to foster dulles was
interviewed and in there he says part of
my job was to carry the collapsible
lectern and a little seal in the front
that said secretary of state and uh
it was through those arrival and
departure statements that most americans
came to know who john foster dulles was
how many people had been into these
princeton
archives before you got there anybody a
few uh some of the material hadn't been
uh liberated yet or uh
declassified
but also there's so many pieces in there
that
not everybody would recognize i give you
one example that i found that nobody has
seen before and it really struck me in
these archives they're not just papers
there's boxes with all kinds of stuff
so i found a couple of envelopes full of
snapshots just family pictures black and
white
pictures
and i looked through them and i was
quite surprised to see a picture of alan
dulles's wife
standing in front of a mayan stella that
i could identify as being in a place
called bananera where the united fruit
company had its big plantation in
guatemala then i saw other snapshots of
clover dulles the wife of allen going
off into little villages in guatemala
and
shopping at markets she obviously became
fascinated with guatemalan culture and
then to my
amazement i found photos of ellen
dulles's weekend house in long island
from the outside it looks like all the
other houses but when you see the
pictures inside in the living room
you'll see the entire room is covered
with guatemalan fabrics and there are
guatemalan artifacts everywhere what it
means is that
guatemala was a daily physical presence
in the life of alan dulles while he was
sitting around planning to destroy the
democratic government there
you're going to end it
i don't know whether it's psychic
psychiatry or
psychology but i want to read this
sentence
neurophysiologists
evolutionary biologists
and social and cognitive psychologists
have made remarkable discoveries about
the working of the brain that are highly
relevant to cold war history
they've developed uh concepts like
group think and confirmation bias
what they're telling us now is that
there's something in our brain that
makes us interpret
everything that we see in ways that
fit into our pre-accepted pre-existing
conceptions so for example uh we
believed
that uh neutralist governments were all
tools of the kremlin uh there was no
evidence for this but i found this uh
document by the uh brazilian ambassador
here in washington he met with foster
dulles and he said i and he wrote back
to his uh foreign ministry i asked
dulles how do you know
that the land reform program in
guatemala was ordered by the kremlin and
foster dulles replied it is true that we
have no evidence but we are proceeding
on the assumption that it must be so
so the idea that guatemalans would
decide to adopt a policy in guatemala
that only had to do with guatemala had
nothing to do with the cold war
was inconceivable to the dulles brothers
they thought everything in the world was
part of the cold war so when they saw
something like a nationalization of oil
in iran or
acts aimed at restricting united fruit
company in guatemala
their mind was
programmed to believe
that these must have been kremlin plots
and so they ignored evidence to the
contrary and embraced whatever shred
they could find that seemed to confirm
their bias
what do you think of the dulleses were
back today though when it comes to
communism that they were so vigorously
opposed to that there's not much of it
left in the world
i think they'd be quite shocked at the
way
the world victorious though
i think they never believed that there
would have been a negotiated solution
and that you could just wait out
the communists and ultimately communism
would fall under its own weight that was
the argument for example that george
cannon was making and george cannon
clashed violently with foster dulles
foster fired him from the state
department because the state department
was not big enough for someone like
george cannon and someone like foster
dulles cannon was saying
let's take this doctrine of containment
and let's wait the soviets out
ultimately their system will fall foster
dulles hated the idea of containment he
said we need a policy of rollback we are
going to push the communists back but of
course he never really did that here's a
communist in our hemisphere who is still
alive today and this is from 1959
fidel castro
why with that attitude have there been
so many executions across cuba without
open free trials
not so many how many
i don't know exactly about
two or three dozen of criminals
because i think that just
is the first thing necessary
for the happiness of the country
interviewed by stuart novens of cbs back
in 1959
what impact did alan dallas have on that
situation there
the idea that a
radical leader could emerge so close to
the american shores was terrifying for
the american government the idea that
they could simply say well castro is
doing what he wants he's very popular
and there's no need for us to be hostile
to him this was of course before he had
embraced the soviets was impossible it
was unthinkable to them and not only
did they believe it was impossible for
the united states to coexist with castro
but they honestly believed that with a
couple of thousand men they could spark
a national uprising against castro the
idea that castro could be
critical of the united states and still
hugely popular among his own people was
inconceivable to them
john foster dallas died of cancer
how old was he do you remember
he wasn't that old he was in his late
60s
and he spent about six months declining
very rapidly
and what about alan ellis what did he
end up dying of i know you said he had
alzheimer's alan dulles died ultimately
of heart failure but he had a whole
series of ailments he became quite heavy
couldn't move very well
and
he
in his obituaries you see a lot more
mixed reviews because by the time he
died in the late 60s of course many of
the cia plots had already started to
come out and the negative sides of his
record were becoming clear when foster
dulles died in the 50s that hadn't
happened yet so everybody was mourning
him
you talk about something that you had to
write this a long time ago that is very
much in the news in the last month
exceptionalism and you define it as the
view that the united states has a right
to impose its will
because it knows more sees farther and
lives on a higher moral plane than other
nations was to them the dulles is not a
platitude but the organizing principle
of daily life and global politics
i find it quite remarkable to read this
book in the context of what we're living
right in these days
it was the dulles brothers idea you
never negotiate with your enemies you
never talk and ultimately you're going
to win and that's actually the policy
the united states has followed for
almost all the period of the last 60
years but just within the last few weeks
we are seeing quite some break in this
first of all
the president of the united states
wanted permission to launch a bombing
attack against syria but many americans
and many members of congress were
against it and then he picked up the
telephone and called the president of
iran a country with which we've had
great hostility for many years so this
leads me to ask myself i think it's too
early to give an answer
did the dulles era just end this month
have we had 60 years of this dulles
militancy and is it now finally changing
i'm waiting to see if this is a
permanent change or just a little
pendulum swing are there any dulles
still alive there are the
not the next generation but the
generation after that there there still
are several out there uh but they've all
decided to stay out of public life and
uh i'm wondering if i'll hear from any
of them after the publication of this
book and what are your plans for another
book
i'm always interested in why we are like
this that's my big theme why does the
united states behave the way that it
does in the world now this book is a
biography it's a biography of the dulles
brothers but it's more than that i'm
using the framework of biography to ask
this larger question
why do we behave the way we do in the
world and whatever my next book is
it will be another way
to ask and try to answer that question
our guest has been stephen kinser he
spent 20 plus years with the new york
times as a reporter and now teaches at
brown university the book is called the
brothers john foster dulles allen dulles
and their secret world war i thank you
very much thank you
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
qna.org q a programs are also available
as c-span podcasts
[Music]
you